la mission d'information qu'ovide
a jugé nécessaire de de faire le point à
ce stade de l'épidémie sur ses
perspectives d'évolution
on va dire à moyen terme et
éventuellement à long terme voit la
raison pour laquelle nous avons intitulé
cette audition le variant au micro et
après notre pays est actuellement encore
dans la vague au micron il faut rappeler
que nos services d'hospitalisation sont
encore très lourdement
chargé par cette parcelle vac ça fait
plusieurs semaines que les services de
réanimation voit plus de 70% de leurs
lits occupés par des patients atteints
du coc vide et que nous sommes toujours
dans des déprogrammations de soins donc
dans un impact sur la chaîne de soins
qui est important mais enfin il semble
que laval pic soit passé que l'épidémie
soit en en décroissance assez rapide
d'ailleurs et que pour reprendre
l'expression
usité des jours meilleurs soit en vue
fait ce que ces jours meilleurs seront
durables est-ce que qu'elles vont être
les perspectives pour les mois à venir
est ce qu'il faut maintenant espérer une
sortie de crise est ce que sera sera
simplement une accalmie est ce que le
risque d'un ralentissement du reflux et
de l'apparition de nouveaux variants est
élevé dans quelle mesure le niveau
actuel de couverture vaccinale et
l'immunité qui découlent du haut niveau
de contamination ces dernières semaines
nous met à l'abri et puis quels
enseignements pouvons nous tirer pour
l'avenir des crises passées de la
connaissance des crises sanitaires passé
et des modèles qui sont actuellement en
cours d'élaboration
alors pour nous éclairer sur ces
différents enjeux nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir ce matin trois
personnalités qui ont des points de vue
on va dire différents enfin je veux dire
en focale
de fait de leur pratique professeurs et
rico qui est infectiologues à paris à
l'ap-hp vitoria colza qui était pile et
milo gist et directrice de recherche à
l'institut pierre louis d'épidémiologie
et de santé publique il parle d'une
serre mais de la sorbonne universités et
le professeur bruno lina qui est donc en
visioconférence avec nous vous êtes
virologues du chef de service à
l'institut des agents infectieux du chu
de lyon et membre du conseil
scientifique
à tous les trois je voudrais d'abord
adressé tous nos remerciements d'avoir
accepté de participer à cette réflexion
et de venir nous faire partager le fruit
de vote de vos réflexions donc je vais
vous céder la parole sans attendre à
chacun à tour de rôle pour une dizaine
de minutes si vous voulez bien et je ne
doute pas que nos rapporteurs ont une
liste impressionnante de questions après
à vous poser tant vraiment les
responsables
politiques que nous sommes avons des
interrogations sur la suite de cette
épidémie et sur les mesures à prendre
bien sûr pour protéger nos concitoyens
c'est évidemment un objectif que nous
partageons tous on commence avec vos
professeurs comme si vous voulez bien
alors par contre il faut mettre votre
micro parce que la séance est enregistré
les diffuser en direct sur le site
internet du sénat elle fera l'objet d'un
compte rendu
comme ça ça va avec le marché très bien
même d'abord bon jour et merci la
confiance que vous nous témoignez ans en
me demandant mon expertise
alors je vais vous avouez quand même que
j'arrive ici en toute modestie surtout
avec le professeur bruno lina
qui je pense est certainement celui qui
en france connaît le mieux le problème
des coronavirus et des virus
respiratoires et qui est je pense
beaucoup plus compétents que moi dans le
domaine
voilà alors moi je peux juste vous dire
rapidement quelle est ma boussole
parce que je ne vois pas dans une boule
de cristal donc ma boussole depuis le
début d'épidémie
c en est en fait historique c'est-à-dire
il ya une référence historique
dont je suis tout à fait étonné qu'elle
était négligé comme ça par les
politiques des scientifiques les
épidémiologistes et autres je suis très
étonné l'histoire n'intéresse plus
personne je vous le dis franchement
en médecine c'est un fait depuis déjà
une dizaine ou une vingtaine d'années
malheureusement et les médecins que nous
formons n'ont plus aucune connaissance
historique
ils sont très bons en mathématiques très
bon physique très bon chimie seront
certainement des futurs prix nobel mais
je ne suis pas sûr que nous formons des
médecins qui en tout cas et la fibre
humaniste
historique hippocratique devrais je dire
donc moi ma référence est historique il
ya eu déjà une épidémie de coronavirus
en 1890 alors elle a été appelée
malheureusement la grippe russe ce qui
fait que ça ne facilite pas les choses
pour retrouver son origine mais
il est un fait que c'était très
certainement une épidémie de coronavirus
c'est l épidémie du coronavirus hausse
et 43 c'est à dire en fait monsieur linh
à vous expliquer ça mieux que moi mais
il ya quatre coronavirus avec lesquelles
nous vivons de façon endémique je parle
pas des deux je parle pas du maire ce
par exemple qui est cantonnée à la
péninsule arabique ni du strass qui a
disparu et donc ces quatre coronavirus
avec lesquelles nous vivons en toute
harmonie depuis des décennies il a bien
fallu qu'ils arrivent à un moment on
sait pour trois d'entre eux qui sont
arrivés il ya très très longtemps à
cause des de l'horloge moléculaire vous
savez on peut remonter à l'origine de
l'apparition des virus noront c'est pour
trois d'entre eux qui sont arrivés à
très longtemps pour le quatrième le
fameux os et 43 où on sait qu'il est
arrivé en 1890 enfin l'hiver 1889 1890
il ya eu à cette époque là il ya eu des
descriptions par des médecins qui ont
bien identifié que ce n'était pas la
grippe que c'était autre chose que la
grippe ils l'ont guidé cette époque-là
des médecins français notamment parisien
la première vague épidémique qui
arrivait en décembre 81 9 janvier 90
1889 1890 a fait environ 500 morts par
jour à paris
donc c'était un très bon modèle
historique je pense je regrette vraiment
beaucoup que c'est intéresser personne
et donc ce qu'on apprend sur 7 sur cette
épidémie de ses 43 c'est que il ya eu
plusieurs vagues épidémiques successives
les premières vagues épidémiques
rêver l'hiver comme l'été et donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai toujours dit que l'été
évidemment le virus circulera - pour des
raisons
tout à fait logique mais que forcément
il y en aurait je me basais sur cette
épidémie de den osse 43 et puis ensuite
les vagues sont devenus de plus en plus
espacées de moins en moins haute une
immunité collective c'est fait et
aujourd'hui on vit avec l'os et 43 qui
est parmi nous j'en ai encore vu un à
deux cas il ya un an qui était
d'ailleurs un cas particulièrement
graves chez un adulte d'une quarantaine
d'années qui a atterri en réanimation ce
qui prouve que les autres coronavirus
peuvent aussi envoyer en réanimation
sauf que comme cd coronavirus que nous
rencontrons dans l'enfance parce que ce
sont des virus qui circule très
largement
à l'école au collège et au lycée quand
on arrive à l'âge adulte c'est moins
grave c'est un principe général en
maladies infectieuses
qui est de dire
que
les infections virales sont très souvent
en général moins graves chez l'enfant
que chez l'adulte c'est à dire il vaut
mieux les attraper chez l'enfant que
chez l'adulte c'est quelque chose qui
est très connue de nous infectiologues
historiquement nos maîtres nous l'ont
appris la varicelle par exemple pour
vous prendre un exemple il vaut mieux la
proie la trappe et dans l'enfance que la
trappe l âge adulte est d'ailleurs à un
moment aux états unis à une vingtaine
d'années trentaine d'années les parents
organisent mmd varicelle parti pour que
leurs enfants soient contaminés pendant
l'enfance était beaucoup moins grave que
d'être contaminés à l'âge adulte il ya
la même chose il ya la même chose pour
la rougeole la rougeole bassée - grahc
une maladie grave un de toute façon même
chez l'enfant mais c'est quand même
moins grave chez l'enfant que chez
l'adulte comment on s'en est rendu
compte à l'occasion de l'épidémie de
rougeole qui a eu lieu il ya quelques
années en france donc voilà il ya des
grands principes comme ça de maladies
infectieuses un autre principe
qui est générale c'est que en général
quand un virus mute pluie stransky
gagnant transmissibilité il le perd en
pathogénicité et donc c'est un peu ce
qu'on est en train d'observer avec le
omicron c'est à dire que le home itron
est beaucoup plus transmissible beaucoup
moins pathogène enfin moins pathogène en
tout cas et d'ailleurs on voit tout
l'hymen toute la population française
est en train de s'immuniser
avec l'eau mikron malgré des vaccins etc
donc voilà je mets de boussole pour être
clair 740 maintenant être enregistrés
non mais je suis pas inquiet du tout
donc voila mais de boussole c'est
l'histoire les maladies infectieuses et
c'est les connaissances que j'ai
acquises en tant qu infectiologues parce
que je suis pas un infectiologue
uniquement
orienté sur une maladie particulière
comme par exemple l'infection vih ou
même le coville aujourd'hui c'est un
infectiologue et une vision que je
revendique comme étant très large de ma
spécialité
c'est voilà c'est comme ça que j'en suis
arrivé
à dire ça donc principalement
connaissance historique de l'épidémie de
grippe russe dit que l'eprus de 1889
1890 qui a duré trois à cinq ans et
c'est pour ça qu'au début j'ai dit que
cette épidémie durerait trois à cinq ans
j'en disais quelles sont vos sources
mamés source était l'histoire voilà tout
simplement je pense que sa valeur france
atteignant de plus en plus on aura
évidemment des resucées je pense
hivernale notamment mais ça va finir par
s'installer parmi nous comme les autres
comme les quatre autres corps et navires
us voilà après on peut toujours faire
des scénarios catastrophe mais je ne
verse pas dans ce catastrophisme la même
si je dois reconnaître que la vérité
c'est qu'on n'en sait strictement rien
bien évidemment on peut élaborer un
seigneur un scénario rassurant comme on
peut c'est élaboré un scénario
catastrophe mais l'histoire des
épidémies d'histoire des maladies
infectieuses nous enseigne ce que je ma
vision optimiste des choses pour le
moyen terme et le long termes bien alors
on va pas passer aux questions tout de
suite mais je suis sûr que ça démange eu
beaucoup vos propos introductif merci
beaucoup je propose qu'on reste dans le
l'agent infectieux avant de passer à
l'épidémiologie et donc qu'on donne la
parole à bruno lina si
tout le monde est d'accord deux
professeurs
oui un souci jeu halo si oui je vais
essayer de partager mon écran si vous
voulez bien
je vais parler d'invasion quelques voilà
exactement donc je ne sais pas si
celui-ci vous voyez là oui très bien
très bien merci
j'ai l'impression j'essaie de passer en
mode plein écran oui on voit très bien
tu vois très bien
d'accord
cc c'est juste donc pour et ses hommes
de vous donner quelques quelques à la
fois une analyse et les perspectives sur
l'évolution du virus et en étant
vraiment avec une focale très
virologiques et vous allez voir que
c'est toujours très intéressant de dire
ce à la lumière de ce qui vient nous
explique éric parce que c'est assez
complémentaires donc je veux représenter
cyrus fait ce virus globalement on a
fait connaissance avec lui de façon
beaucoup plus importante puisque l'on
appelait comme connaissance initialement
lorsqu'il a émergé ce qu un virus c'est
un virus qu'on appelle comme ça parce
qu'il a un effet dix ans couronne
lorsqu'on le regarde au microscope
électronique vous voyez ici aussi ces
spicules qui sont représentés dasu un
schéma dessiné qui sont assez faibles en
nombre la surface du virus mais qui sont
extrêmement performante pour faire du
virus est capable d'entrer dans les
cellules est rare que l'on regarde un
tout petit peu les l'épidémie pour moi
je considère qu'aujourd'hui on a quatre
phases évolutif qui ont déjà été
observés la première phase 6 la phase
d'émergence c'est la phase qui est
le transmission d'un virus qui sort d'un
réservoir animal ce réservoir animal
très vraisemblablement c'est une
chauve-souris et on se base sur le fait
que des séquences
que l'on a détecté chez les premiers
patients des séquences des virus que
l'on a détecté chez des premiers
patients pour lesquels on a pu faire des
analyses microbiologiques poussé on
montrait qu' il y avait une homologie
qui était extrêmement forte avec des
virus de chauves-souris et donc il est
probable
réservoir de la chauve souris a permis
une transmission du virus à l'homme
cette transmission elle se fait en
général mais pas toujours par un
réservoir animal intermédiaire un autre
intermédiaire il avait été évoqué le
pangolin ça n'est pas le fond gaulle a
en tout cas pas ceux qu'on a investigué
mais cette notion de réservoir un
terreau misère est important parce que
théoriquement ce virus n'est pas capable
de passer directement de bâches ou
celui-là l'homme il a bien besoin
d'avoir un adaptateur et cet adaptateur
il dit quelque part dans la faune
animale et j'y reviendrai parce que dans
les perspectives du futur il faut qu'on
garde ça en tête la deuxième phase de
l'évolution qui est très précoce juste
après les berges ans on peut dire que
l'émergence c'était décembre 2010 9
novembre ou décembre 2019 la diffusion
c'est février mars 2020 et cette
diffusion à l'elysée à une évolution du
virus dans une région très particulière
j'ai remis si la représentation du virus
et on voit et si cette protéine de
spicules qui est celle qui permet au
virus s'attache et sur le récepteur
cellulaire et le récepteur à ce2 et bien
là la forme de la molécule spicules
n'est plus la même à partir de fin de
fin février début mars tout simplement
parce que une mutation est survenu dans
cette protéine à un endroit qui permet à
cette spicules de en quelque sorte
s'ouvrir un petit peu plus et de
favoriser la capacité d'attachement de
l'ensemble des molécules présentes à la
surface du virus qui ont acquis cette
mutation eh bien ces virus sont plus
infectieux et on a donc un gain
d'infection cité et un gain
potentiellement de transmissibilité qui
a commencé à apparaître tout simplement
avec cette première évolution génétique
qui a permis la diffusion d'un gène au
groupe qui s'appelle le jeu roger qui
est devenu le logo majoritaire la
troisième phase d'évolution c'est une
évolution qui a été observé à l'échelle
planétaire
pratiquement de façon concomitante à
quelques semaines près dans trois
continents différents en europe en
afrique et en amérique du sud avec ce qu
on a convenu comme étant une convergence
évolutive des virus et cette convergence
évolutive des virus a conduit à ce que
les virus d'ein ce que l'on appelle dans
notre jargon virologue de fitness le
fitness c'est un mot britannique qui a
pas de traduction qui soit aussi dans ce
qui existe en français c'est en fait une
capacité de transmission et d'infections
et donc ces virus ont évolué de façon à
améliorer
leurs capacités de transmission et
d'infections avec 3 puis un quatrième
variante dont vous avez entendu parler
un les variants alfa beta gamma puis les
variants delta et ses mariant alfa beta
gamma et delta ils sont procédé
sensiblement par les mêmes processus
évolutif pour améliorer ce fitness en
changeant de nouveau quelques éléments
de composition de cette protéine de
spicules qui entraîne une meilleure
qualité de l'attachement du virus a
sombré cette heure
puis il y a eu l'apparition du variant
au micron et là c'est une évolution qui
est différente qui probablement a été
essentiellement piloté par la nécessité
d'un échappement immunitaire et on voit
bien qu'en fait on a quatre ces quatre
phases qui sont des phases qui se
succèdent les unes avec les autres et ce
qui me permet de dire aujourd'hui que
c'est probablement une évolution par
échappant et militaires qui donne cette
épidémie shoes est représentée ici des
courbes voyez là c'était des courbes des
variants alfa beta et delta et on voit
la courbe de l'évolution au micron en
france comme dans d'autres pays ce virus
est
vraiment transmissibles et il a acquis
son potentiel de transmission à la fois
en faisant en partie la même chose qui
avait fait affable et al gamaa et delta
en augmentant son potentiel de
transmissibilité mais aussi en
installant un système d'échappement et
militaires et cet échappement et
militaires on est capable de le
documenter de leur présenter assez
simplement sur une espèce de cartes une
cartographie antigénique à 7 ce qui est
représentée ici qui est en fait vous
avez ici le virus initiale et les tout
premiers virus qui ont émergé et à
partir de ce virus initial les virus ont
évolué aussi bien sur le modèle
génétique que sur le mode d'échappement
immunitaire mais cet essai points et
militaire initialement il est marginal
il est marginale parce qu'il n'y a pas
de pression militaire but il ya encore
énormément de personnes qui n'avaient
pas été infectés et puis petit à petit
ces virus ont commencé à développer un
tout petit peu des chambres immunitaire
un plus on est loin de l'épicentre
initial qui était le virus guan plus en
échappe à la réponse immunitaire que
l'on peut avoir avec les virus initiaux
et on voit que le positionnement du
virus au micron le montre très à
distance des virus initiaux on sort des
cercles concentriques initiaux pour
commencer peut-être un travail qui est
d'un travail de remplacement massif d'un
virus qui présente comme je vous le
disais la combinaison d'une augmentation
d'un potentiel de transmissibilité du
fait de mutation intrinsèque qui
améliore l'attachement du virus et
récepteurs comme l'avaient fait les
virus initiaux mais en plus et un
échappement et militaire c'est à dire
que ce virus même s'il n'est pas capable
de donner des formes graves il échappe à
un certain nombre deux anticorps qui ont
été générés au cours des infections
passé ou des vaccinations et c'est le
fait qu'il est capable d'échapper
entraîne un mécanisme de rang placement
extrêmement rapide beaucoup plus rapide
que ce qu'on avait vu avec les phases
initiales avec un virus qui augmente de
façon
extrêmement élevé son niveau de
circulation et sas complètement les
autres vieux jeu parce que
intrinsèquement du fait de cet
échappement immunitaire il s'éloigne des
virus initiaux et il s'éloigne de
l'immunité qui avait commencé à
s'installer et psy qui permet donc de
faire disparaître tout ce qui est à
l'intérieur des premiers cercles pour ne
maintenir que ce qui est à l'extérieur
de ce cercle de protection et c'est le
principe du de l'évolution moléculaire
des virus alors là je vous montre une
image qui est une image compliquée mais
vous allez voir c'est finalement très
simple c'est ici en quelque sorte un
arbre généalogique des virus tels qu'ils
ont pu apparaître initialement la racine
se trouve ici ses tout premiers virus là
qui sont identifiés là qui sont les vars
et de les virus initiaux qui ont
commencé l'épidémie en chine puis
progressivement sont apparus ce que josé
appelait les violences utile c'est le
groupe g et tous les virus et c'est ce
qui avait acquis la première la première
mutation tous les virus qui circule
actuellement sont des descendants se
gênent le groupe chez ea l'interdît j'ai
le groupe g on a eu trois événements qui
sont survenus précocément comme je
l'expliqué émergence de alpha bêta et
gamma puis les merlans ce virus aise
delta et lorsqu'on regarde les racines
d'émergence de l'ensemble de ce virus
elles reviennent tous sur la base c'est
ce que je représente par les sig les
cercles bleus ici on est dans
l'évolution moléculaire des virus
initiaux et ses ongles des descendantes
véreux chine sur il en est dit comment
pareil pour au micron qui n'est
probablement sur la même racine que
delta est peut-être khalfa aussi avec un
virus qui finalement est très proche des
virus qui soit et est immédiatement
apparu après le début de l'été en
revanche lorsque l'on regarde
l'évolution de micron on voit qu micron
et s'est représenté par le cercle rouge
ici à générer une descendance qui
s'appelle le béal 2 et le met un point
d'eux est un virus qui pour la première
fois n'apparaît pas au niveau de la
racine de l'ensemble du groupe des virus
qui avaient circulé jusqu'à présent et
donc c'est un signal faisant imaginer
que ce virus au micron du fait qu'il a
commencé à échapper à la pression et
militaires préexistantes il cette
pression et militaires jouent un rôle
majeur de contrôle sur l'ensemble des
autres virus mais moins sûr au micron et
que dès lors au micro et capable de
générer une descendance qui pourrait
faire imaginer et c'est une hypothèse
n'est pas la certitude qu'on rentre dans
une phase où on va avoir des descendants
non plus des virus y messieurs mais du
virus au micron qui serait capable
d'évoluer et donc si on reprend tout ça
être en le replaçant le contexte de la
logique d'évolution d'un virus émergent
d'une manière générale on voit bien
qu'on a d'abord
des mutations qui surviennent selon le
calendrier en fonction de l'impact du
fitness mais petit à petit c'est un pack
de fitness va avoir moins d'importance
pour céder la place à la pression et
militaire qui va être le moteur de
l'évolution des virus émergents et une
des analystes que je fais mais qui est
aussi une hypothèse c'est que avec la
vaccination qui a entraîné finalement un
niveau d'immunisation collectif beaucoup
plus rapide que ce que l'on aurait pu
obtenir si on avait simplement eu
l'immunisation qui se faisait par le
biais des infections naturel eh bien il
est possible que cette logique évolutive
est entraîné un essai de deux d'impact
en terme de durée sur l'évolution de
l'ensemble des étapes que doivent subir
le virus
sarce cause d'eux pour devenir un virus
banal comme l'expliquait comme
l'expliquait tout à l'heure et rit comme
et devenir un virus qui serait capable
simplement de donner au fil du temps des
infections qui petit à petit vont
devenir de moins en moins importante du
fait de l'immunité qui auraient été
installés non seulement l'immunité
humorale pour lequel on sait que un
échappement est possible mais par contre
beaucoup moins au niveau de l'immunité
cellulaire si elle est durable et qui il
protège actuellement contre tous les
virus qui circule donc et je terminerai
avec cette hypothèse aujourd'hui ce que
l'on peut imaginer sur le plus probable
à court terme c'est qu'il est il est
probable qu'on se trouve dans une
situation où on est dans une logique
d'évolution par dérive moléculaire et
anti g depuis le b1 en particulier avec
l'exemple du pa2 qui était le virus qui
émergeait qui est elle en fait le groupe
génétique au micron l'initiale mais
cette
perspective plus probable aujourd'hui on
veut pas complètement
imaginez que on reste quand même un
petit peu par hasard chez match de
montrer dans une logique de co évolution
qui est à la fois de dérive antigénique
les moléculaire et d'une capacité de
grains de fitness c'est à dire aussi
avec une meilleure transmissibilité ou
peut-être
d'autres mutations qui peuvent survenir
dans d'autres gènes qui pourraient
conférer des avantages à des descendants
du virus nos micros malgré tout ça c'est
assez serré l'hypothèse la plus
favorable et peut-être la plus probable
mais mais il faut garder un sas entre
d'autres perspectives en tête c'est à
dire que ces virus on sait qu'ils nous
ont pris par surprise déjà très
nombreuses fois et où ça ne sera pas est
ce qu'il y a
évolution il faut garder en tête
absolument c'est la capacité de ce virus
peut avoir à recombiner c'est-à-dire
mélanger des gènes du sascoc de avec
d'autres coronavirus humains comme os et
43 et qui pourrait conférer un
changement de à la fois de trop fils
mais peut-être de capacité de
transmission et peut-être de pathogénèse
et donc il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
surveille ça de façon très étroite et et
l'importance de la surveillance
moléculaires d'un séquençage de ce point
de vue est extrêmement important la
deuxième hypothèse qu'il faut qu'on
garde en tête c'est la capacité de ce
qu'on appelle la rétro zoonoses ce virus
six sorties du réservoir animal il est
rentré chez l'homme mais on sait que
l'homme est capable d'infecter des
animaux les animaux d'élevage vous savez
qu'il ya eu des histoires d'infections
d'élevages dams terre
à hong kong il ya eu des histoires
d'infection chez les vies sont en europe
ya des histoires d'infection des
cervidés en amérique du nord et il ya
toute une série d'animaux de compagnie
et animaux de sow qui ont été infectés
par ce virus mais lorsque ce virus
humain rentrer dans un nouveau réservoir
animal est bien le virus reprend une
capacité évolutive
on retourne sur les initiales de la
dérive par la pression à la fois de
gains de fitness c'est ce nouvel hôte et
potentiellement de pression militaire et
tout ça en classe un nouveau processus
évolutif qu'il faut pour lequel il faut
être extrêmement vigilant parce que si
ce virus qui sort de l'homme et qui va
dans ce réservoir évolué dans ce
réservoir est capable de retourner vers
loeb c'est un virus modifiés qui pourra
ressembler un virus de la racine d'une
nouvelle racines comme celui qui était
qui avaient émergé de la chauve souris
en 2000 en 2019 donc voila un petit peu
les éléments que je voulais partager
avec vous pour ce pour presser éclairé
au maximum cette discussion
merci beaucoup pour
pour toutes ces explications absolument
passionnante je passais la parole à
vitoria colza qui est beaucoup sollicité
par le sénat
depuis un moment qu'ils étaient une
dizaine de jours à la commission des
affaires sociales pour un sujet beaucoup
plus on va dire immédiat la question du
pass vaccinale voilà mais là c'est sur
cette question des perspectives à moyen
terme qu'on souhaite entendre vos
capacités d'analysé épidémiologique
bonjour à tous et à toutes merci
beaucoup monsieur le président pour
m'avoir invité je voulais donc que gérer
trompe peut-être quelques éléments qui a
déjà déjà été touchée et je répartir
voilà daily mail ya donc le court terme
parce que celle là où on a plus
d'éléments et à partir de là aussi en
perspective qui sert à épidémiologique
sur la base de ce qui a été déjà
mentionné
pour ce qui concerne la suite
aujourd'hui 17 wagons micro on a sans
doute des éléments qui sont très
positives cette décrue assez rapide
il va il va y avoir que même en effet
râle et y sont aussi dues aux vacances
scolaires les effets de la saisonnalité
parce qu'on approche l'été comment on a
déjà vu et il a été déjà remarqué ça
n'empêche que même en circulation virale
massa favorise
donc comme ça ça défavorise ou une
transmission c'est à dire à cause de
comportements et à cause même de
température et humidité il ya moins de
chance de propagation par contre là
d'autres éléments qui sont un peu
opposés à tout ça et on peut le voir
aussi à l'étranger par exemple le
royaume uni après une décrue assez
rapide a connu maintenant et encore sur
cette situation un plateau à haute
incidence
qui a démarré a ensuite un
sou gérer ou baisses successives mais
qui s'est arrêté sur un autre plateau
donc là sont des éléments que même à
prendre en compte comme possible dans la
suite de la semaine des semaines à venir
il y à l'autre élément qui a été déjà
mentionné par le professeur bruno lina
qui est la présence le set bariant ba2
notamment nous notre vague a été
dominée par le béa en comme d'ailleurs
pour les restes d'europe ba2 aujourd'hui
un croissance en france comme dans un
parmi d'autres pays et il ya des
premiers éléments qui vient de plusieurs
études il ya en études danois qui montre
par exemple sont étudiées puis plus de
8000 foyers
infectées dans les mois de décembre
janvier par le ba1 à ba2 elles sont été
4 capable de montrer une accélération
donc de la propagation comme toujours
cette accélération peut dépendre soit
d'une transmission intrinsèque du virus
plus élevé soit d'une capacité de
réaffecter ce qui a été la clé de succès
dit au micro en général il y a d'autres
études qui vient dé sortir il ya
vraiment quelques jours des études
danalyse houle
dans les laboratoires on va comparer la
protection des anticorps contre des
infections ils sont montrés que après
infection ba1 il y a quand même une
petite baisse de protection d'anticorps
contre infections ba2 ça veut dire qu'il
pourrait y avoir effectivement cette
capacité d'évasion immunitaire encore un
peu plus fort pour ba2 c'est qui va
exactement dans les lignes les
prospectives que prône lina disait
auparavant et là c'est pour la suite
très rapide sur les court terme sur
lesquels effectivement on en plus
d'éléments parce qu'on peut se baser sur
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui d'ailleurs sur un
gars on a un en perspective sur moyen et
long terme ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec mes collègues il ya deux grands
scénarios qui on a bien évidemment en
tête d'un côté l'émergence de nouveaux
variants sait qui est tout à fait
possible on a quand même des situations
aussi dans le reste du monde où
l'incidence resté très élevé en silence
élévé ça veut dire qu'il ya des
probabilités plus élevé d'avoir une
mutation qui après pourrait devenir
dominant pour certains caractéristiques
propres des cette mutation
et l'autre est là répondre évidemment à
7,7 c'est cela c'est très compliqué on
n'a pas des moyens parce que notre
réponse c'est l'impact qui va avoir sur
la population va dépendre notamment de
la transmissibilité contagiosité
pathogénicité de ces variants et surtout
aussi au moment où ces vaillants
éventuellement arrive un population
qu'elle sert à l'état d'immunité de la
population
on sait bien qu'il y à qui la relation
entre hôtes virus et des vaccins n'est
pas statique dans les temps évoluent
avec les temps les anticorps baisse même
si on est capable de maintenir une
efficacité très élevé par rapport aux
formes graves il ya quand même des
enjeux qui sont aussi dues à la
transmissibilité éventuellement si élevé
le cadeau micron est excellent pour
montrer ça on a quand même à l'impact
sanitaire important même si la
pathogénicité le plus faible réduite par
rapport aux variants précédente à cause
du fait qu'on a il ya une infection
majeur d'une grande partie de la
population en france donc en grand
nombre de personnes infectées après même
si les probabilités sont plus réduites
de passer à l'hôpital il ya quand même
en grand nombre de personnes
hospitalisées à cause de ça et puis là
il ya l'autre scénario qui est l'un des
mis cité dont on parle beaucoup ces
derniers temps la grippe donc on a un
déficit est saisonnier est le scénario
qui est le
celui qui a porté
avant avec puce voilà de force dans
cette communication je pense qu'il ya
aussi d'autres scénarios possibles en
plusieurs maladies qui sont endémiques
qui font des flambées épidémiques une
équipe différente surtout tout ça ça va
dépendre comme dit si le professeur
comme ça va dépendre de la capacité de
ce virus d'infecter certains tranche
d'âge par rapport à d'autres et ça
dépendra aussi de notre capacité
démoniser aussi les populations pas
seulement à travers l'infection mais
aussi à travers la vaccination on voit
bien la vaccination par exemple en
france des enfants qui n'a pas décollé
commun comme ailleurs dans d'autres pays
je pense qu'un élément est donc que pour
répondre à ça bien évidemment on compte
s'attend que la saisonnalité devis reçus
parce qu'il s'agit d'un virus
respiratoires va jouer un rôle important
des signes synchronisation au cours du
temps et je pense qu'il ya un aspect qui
normalement n'est pas mais pas si mise à
l'avant qui est la prévisibilité de sept
de ses timings dans les sens qu'on aura
entre deux notions en soutien le
scénario de la grippe saisonnière en
tête il y a plusieurs avantages qu'ils
ne sont pas là des mici t elle même de
voilà de la maladie mais c'est aussi
l'effet constatant d'avoir ou vague
hivernale et ça change complètement
aussi notre capacité de réponse bien
évidemment parce que on peut
localiser dans les temps la période où
il faudra répondre et donc aussi
éventuellement planifié en campagne de
vaccination focalisée pour ça
aujourd'hui en les vaccinés la
vaccination a bien évidemment april le
démarrage début de l'année dernière puis
elle a été accélérée pour faire face à
la vague estivale delta et puis les
troisièmes donc le booster la troisième
dose a été accélérée là aussi pour faire
face à la vague hivernale delta qui
puisse se transformer dans le vague au
micro donc on à aulas était toujours un
peu à la voilà on a on a dû courir après
ce qui s'est passé l'anticipation à
travers la vaccination c'est bien que
dans les cadres de la grippe saisonnière
par exemple très important alors les
conditions donc au beau revoir cet
indice il admis cités vont dépendre
effectivement de la capacité des
l'immunité des rester au cours de temps
donc cette décroissance au cours de
temps soit délimité limité à qu'ils
soient de la vaccination en
un scénario probable est que une fois
qu'on accumule un certain nombre de
couches d'immunité
ces couches vont protéger des façons
assez large là la population interne
transmission donc pour réduire des
conséquences aussi les formes graves qui
seront aussi eu même réduite par
l'immunité cellulaire et là la grosse
question est si en tira au délà ou en
dessus d'un certain seuil qu'ils soient
d'acceptabilité qui soit par exemple
jusqu'ici je pense sur la saturation des
hôpitaux seller les critères
informellement utilisé mais là cette
question on peut pas répondre donc si on
va le même un déni que va attendre un
impact sanitaire important qu'on a
connus aujourd'hui on ne peut pas aller
dire encore et je reviens sur l'exemple
fait par les professeurs comme je pense
qu'il ya aussi en caractères des timings
donc à quai même si on aura cette
situation ces scénarios d'endémicité de
la grippe qui pourrait aussi nous
accorder en certains prévisibilité pour
dans la réponse on ne sait pas
exactement combien de temps il faudra
pour y est arrivé
et surtout il faudra pas s'imaginer que
c'est que si ces moments de micron
représente un peu là là le démarrage le
début d'une deuxième partie de cette
pandémie donc d'une sortie il faut pas
s'imaginer non plus que ça sera en 100
mètres sur une piste d'athlétisme très
bien éclairé serra plutôt laon course
j'irai d'étrelles avec plusieurs
obstacles sur la rue et avec un certain
nombre possible de résurgence épidémique
est donc c'est ça tout la difficulté de
la prévisibilité 2 sur le moyen et long
terme
je terminerai la conclusion nous ravit
merci merci beaucoup et on va passer aux
questions commençant par les rapporteurs
roger karoutchi
bon vous dire que je suis rassuré après
un bon et tout ça pas vraiment
moi j'ai une batterie de questions mais
je comprends bien que l'on puisse pas
avoir réponse à tout
sommes pas des scientifiques nous sommes
des élus enfin
bernard lui médecin mais pas moi et on a
beaucoup écouté les autorités politiques
sanitaires loomis et à la santé je
résume je peux revenir sur le passé je
résume depuis allez un bon mois on nous
dit
on commence à imaginer que la pandémie
est derrière nous
omicron nous rassure entre guillemets il
est certes plus contagieux mais plus
transmissible mais il est moins virulent
le résultat c'est que
on est dans une situation totalement
incompréhensible dans le pays
des gens qui font beaucoup moins
attention qui respecte beaucoup moins
les gestes sanitaire parce que on a
diffusé l'idée finalement omicron c'est
la grippe
évidemment tous les jours que dieu fait
on a les statistiques qui nous disent
plus de gens l'hôpital eu 300 morts etc
donc on dit c'est quand même une grippe
d'un certain niveau et on ne comprend
plus où on va un vin autant pardon mais
du temps de delta si je peux dire les
gens étaient inquiets les gens est très
attention on nous disait c'est très
c'est à la fois transmissibles et
dangereux donc
bat campagne de vaccination les gens
font la queue dans les centres de
vaccination aujourd'hui moi mes centres
de vaccination dans les hauts-de-seine y
a personne y a personne tous les
rendez-vous sont dispos et y compris
pour la troisième dose je parle pas
d'eux et il n'y a pas grand monde qui va
faire la première on a très peu augmenté
en réalité la pression pour que les gens
il ya eu même pour la première dose et
donc on est dans une situation un peu
étonnante avec un gouvernement qui nous
a fait voter ya peu le post vaccinales
et qui maintenant 10 ans va finalement
le pas ce match il alors peut-être
l'enlever dès le mois de mars et puis
peut-être que c'est pas la bonne
solution est donc tous ceux qui avaient
des hésitations ce qui était mon cas
mais qui se disait bon fait confiance
parce que vous pourrez on en est on va
pas casser la dynamique pour en sortir
se retrouve dans une situation où on se
dit non mais
on va alors
j'aurai plusieurs questions l'étude 1
j'ai bien entendu que on n'était pas
certain du tout d'en sortir avec ovi
chronique peut-être qu'ils auraient
ensuite
de nouveaux variants bon donc on verra
bien mais un est ce qu'il est possible
et imaginable que l'un des laboratoires
et finalement un vaccin qui puisse
protéger contre l'ensemble des variants
et pas nous dire que bah on n'en sait
rien et il faudra peut-être certes des
rappels mais même les rappels on ne sait
pas trop parce que s qui sont tous
adaptés parce que dans l'esprit public
il faut bien que chacun rende compte moi
je suis triplement vacciner mais quand
on nous dit même triplement vaccinez
vous pouvez l'attraper c'est pas du tout
la même chose que quand on disait
autrefois sur tel ou tel vaccin sur
d'autres d'autres maladies si vous êtes
vacciné vous êtes protégé là vous avez
des sentiments de la protection mais en
réalité vous pouvez la trappe et quand
même et alors qu'on nous dit les formes
graves mais enfin bon on en sait
finalement pas grand chose et donc ça
pousse pas les gens à être disciplinés
aller sur vacciner à respecter gestes
barrières ils ont un peu le sentiment
soit de la fatalité soit de la facilité
mais rarement un sentiment il faut faire
ça pour être protégé est ce que oui ou
non on est susceptible un joueur d'avoir
un vaccin global protecteur
[Musique]
y compris protégeant par rapport à la
transmission deuxième élément on voit
bien que sur la vaccination
beaucoup de gens sont gentils vague
s'ils veulent pas de la rn on nous a
beaucoup parlé d'un novavax pour le
moment au
bon alors on sait même pas où il est
d'ailleurs le novavax parce que il est
assez peu en métropole mois dans les
centres de vaccination le propose port
donc je remets est ce que vraiment il ya
un moyen de s'en sortir enfin
comment est ce que vous vous analysez
alors je vous demande pas un centime en
politique mais comment vous analyser
comment dire
le
le manque de lisibilité
de la politique publique en matière de
lutte contre cette pandémie ya quand
même depuis le début cent trente deux
mille morts il ya des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qu'on est qu ils
l'ont on nous dit manat les chiffres
quand vous donne le jour ou le soir ne
sont plus des chiffres classique puisque
c'est pas vraiment les gens qui viennent
à l'hôpital du fait du coc vide mais
c'est des gens qui viennent à l'hôpital
quelle que soit
la maladie ou le problème mais que l'on
détecte qu'ovide une fois qu'ils sont là
donc on l'aimé qu'ovide mais il meurt
pas dû forcément du coc vide il meurt
pas de magie
ce que je veux dire c'est que il ya une
incompréhension grandissante
entre ce que l'on nous dit est ce que
les gens vont finalement faire à la
limite quelque part il ya six mois un an
quand ce n'est pas l'eau mikron quand le
danger était là la perspective pour la
population et sr terrible mais elles
étaient claires transparentes sur la
discipline à avoir aujourd'hui
on nous dit par exemple le gouvernement
britannique annonce que dans quelques
jours il lèvera complètement le fait que
même pour les cas positifs il ya
nécessité de rester chez soi en clair
vous allez testé positif aux copines
vous pourrez continuer de circuler
c'est incompréhensible enfin je veux
dire on ne peut pas avoir dit aux gens
il faut éviter il faut prendre des
mesures il faut rester chez soi il faut
se protéger pour qu'ensuite des
gouvernements viennent dire zéro
problème vous avez le coc vite vous êtes
positif continuer à les travailler
continue à circuler dans la rue on va
enlever les masques d'abord dans la rue
puis à l'intérieur alors à un moment
où on est complètement perdue alors on
se fit naturellement à ce que les
autorités peuvent nous dire pour
continuer la vie sociale dans ce pays
mais
ça devient très compliqué là j'ai bien
entendu et je suis première dire je
patiente ific je vous promets à dire
sept épis de cette pandémie arrive par
définition évidemment on n'a pas les
éléments évidemment qu'il ya beaucoup de
doutes évidemment il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes
mais pour des politiques et pour l'ess
pour le sénat ça devient très compliqué
de savoir moi j'ai voté le pass
vaccinale gens suivent dire aujourd'hui
ne pas le voter j'aurais dû m'abstenir
parce que je n'y comprends plus rien et
je ne sais plus où j'en suis
bien je pas de commentaires je vais
passer la parole au 2ème rapporteur et
puis je vais demande après je vous
donnerai la parole à tous les trois pour
apporter les réponses qui après mes
collègues voilà mes autres collègues ont
la parole et je demande à ceux qui sont
vision de se signaler dès maintenant
s'ils souhaitent interroger nos
intervenants jean michel arnaud oui
merci au président porto à toutes et à
tous de s'y coller je sais bresse
je rebondis sur une partie de la
question mon collègue roger karoutchi
sur la question tdlv 2 richaud
il a fait allusion à la situation en
grande bretagne il ya également dans
certains pays scandinaves la volonté
l'affirmation de la levée complexe des
restrictions dans les prochaines
semaines
j'aimerais avoir autres votre regard
entre appréciation sur sur ses décisions
et et si vous considérez qu'elles sont
et fiable et au vu de la situation que
vous avez analysé l'évolution
de la forme d'un la forme du virus
qu'est le micro quels sont selon vous
les critères que nous pourrions imaginer
pour que en france de manière objective
et non pas simplement puisque nous
sommes des élus dans un cadre électoral
il faut rassurer la population ouvrir
une nouvelle socialisation un retour à
la vie normale donc on nous considérait
mais qu'est-ce que vous avez vous des
des éléments de suggestions sur les
critères objectifs qui nous
permettraient
de suffisamment l'exemple britannique
exemple c'est à moi je crois sur
lesquels visible on sait le pays
s'appuie en termes de critères pour
pouvoir avancer le la deuxième question
on a parlé beaucoup de vaccination
diminue des seigneurs jeu je voudrais
également avoir votre appréciation sur
l'arrivée sur le marché comme la
commercialisation de médicaments
permettant d'accompagner et de faire en
sorte d'élan klein un patient est
atteint de la maladie de droits traitée
est ce que vous pensez que que ces
médicaments vont rendre vont permettre
d'en dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent d'avoir finalement au troisième
ou 10e après la maladie immunité
personnel la vaccination a maintenant
médicaments permettant d'accélérer le
processus
finalement deux de sortie de crise
troisièmement et je me permets de de
m'appuyer sur la présentation
particulièrement
intéressante d'un point de vue
historique et dr comment vous évoquée
finalement les difficultés à la
communauté scientifique et peut-être se
rode des modules de formation des
médecins manquent de connaissances
historiques puisque on fait allusion à
l'alaric russe il fallait l'inventer
prusse dans le contexte actuel un ep
triana les russes de
est-ce que vous pensez que il faut tirer
des enseignements aussi horreur le
corpus et les modules de formation au
sein de du processus donc d'acquisition
des compétences pour devenir médecin et
si oui selon vous comment faut-il
oeuvrer en ce sens c'est cuit de manière
plus large
j'aimerais également que vous donniez
votre avis aussi possible sinna man sur
le mégalo compliquées entre la côte et
scientifiques et les responsables
publics politiques durant ces deux
dernières années avec finalement
difficultés de diallo et cette
compréhension des enjeux et du partage
de ses enjeux entre la communauté
politique a compté scientifique est
hélas aussi j'aimerais connaître votre
avis pour améliorer et tirer les
enseignements de la crise à laquelle
nous sommes est meilleur dans l'avenir
si si nous devions de confronter une
nouvelle triste jour merci merci je
voudrais avant nous passer à part
complété une des questions de roger
karoutchi sur les perspectives de la
vaccination est ce que il vous paraît
nécessaire utile de maintenir
dans les mois et où années à venir un
haut niveau de protection de la
population par la vaccination jeu je
pense à ce que professeur comme nous a
dit sur l'histoire de ces virus parce
que on doit répondre à cette question en
tout cas et la deuxième que la deuxième
en complément à ce que vous avez dit et
vitoria crise ça et professeurs comme et
monsieur meunier professeur lina
d'ailleurs vous dit un des scénarii
c'est l'émergence de nouveaux variants
professeurs comme nous dit mais
l'histoire des virus que quand un virus
gagnant transmissibilité et moins dans
heureux donc question bon si un nouveau
variant encore moins dangereux que
micron apparaît on va tous convenir que
c'est pas un drame pour nos sociétés
voilà avec ça ça va pas bon mais est ce
que il ya l'hypothèse un nouveau variant
qu'ils soient moins transmissibles et
qu'ils soient plus dangereux est ce que
cette hypothèse évidemment vous n'avez
pas de boule de cristal on l'a bien
entendu mais c'est une hypothèse d'école
on va dire ou es ce que voit là qu'est
quelle probabilité voulu voiliers de
survenir puisque c'est évidemment une
hypothèse qui nous préoccuperait
professeurs comme
[Musique]
alors j'ai à beaucoup de questions un
cours un très grand un très grand un
très grand fut alors il ya deux
principes généraux en maladies
infectieuses que j'ai aussi oublié de
vous donner tout à l'heure mais pour
vous aider à répondre et à y voir plus
clair je pense que dans une infection
émergentes on veut pas s'appuyer sur la
science parce que par définition la
science elle est devant nous quoi s'ils
voulaient beaucoup des choses qui ont
été dites va s'avère un peu fausse vous
l'avez remarqué
effectivement on attribue aux copies des
hospitalisations qui ne devrait pas être
attribué au kovy puisque c'est des
patients qui sont hospitalisés avec un
co vide et non pas pour un co vide c'est
un exemple un mais y en a plein d'autres
évidemment les deux principes sur
lesquels je voulais vous dire revenir
c'est premier principe l'immunité
naturelle est toujours meilleur que
l'immunité vaccinale il n'y a quasiment
pas d'exception en matière de
vaccinologie sauf la vaccination
papillomavirus
on va pas revenir là dessus évidemment
elle a un prix mais en dehors de la
vaccination papillomavirus qui est
meilleur sur les que l'immunité
naturelle probablement on n'est même pas
sûr mais on va dire toutes les autres
infections ce serait la rougeole la
fièvre jaune etc l'immunité naturelle
est meilleur que l'immunité vaccinale
donc si on applique ses locaux vides ce
principe de base des maladies
infectieuses si on applique au vide et
notamment ses ballades pour les enfants
il vaut mieux être infecté naturellement
que être vaccinés parce que l'immunité
vaccinale sera éphémère alors que
l'immunité naturelle
ce sera avec le vide éphémère mais elle
sera moins sera meilleur que limité et
ça a été montré ça a été montré par les
américains l'étude de californie plus
d'un million de personnes l'immunité
naturelle les manières sont des données
anciennes mais pour les responsables
politiques la question est quand même
celle ci tient à le souligner en ce
jeune homme est à l'évidence vous
rappeler c'est que l'immunité naturelle
a un prix oui en terme de conséquences
pour les personnes affectées voilà ce
dont j'allais revenir à lhassa
effectivement et pour illustrer les
propos de monsieur karoutchi
la population française a tout
simplement pris en compte qu mikron
était moins grave que delta c'est tout
c'est aussi simple que ça parce que moi
aussi mon centre de vaccination à
l'hôtel dieu que je mette à l'hôtel dieu
je suis à la pitié salpêtrière il ya
personne personne est en fait pourquoi
y'a personne mais les gens ne sont pas
fous ils ont tous attrapé le coronavirus
au mois de janvier au mois de décembre
il entend plus se vacciner alors qu'ils
ont tous attrapé le coronavirus et moi
je m'étais exprimé très clairement là
dessus j'avais dit que le pass vaccinale
je suis désolé de mai la lecture et
politique vous voulez pas qu'on parle
politique ok même si je pense que c'est
un lieu où on doit un peu parler de
politique mais je pense que c'est
politique et c'est ce que j'avais dit
lepage matinale ne servait strictement à
rien en plus vacciner
les populations enfin quand je dis
strictement rien j'exagère parce que
bien évidemment fallait vacciner les
personnes à risque mais dans la
population générale ça ne servait à rien
d'abord ça on ne sait pas la circulation
du virus sans et surtout ça enfin les
gens n'y comprennent plus rien parce que
vous leur dites il faut vacciner en même
temps tout le monde a chopé coronavirus
toutes nos familles autour de nous tout
le monde et bâle tous nos enfants
étaient malades tous nos petits enfants
étaient malades enfin tout le monde a
été malade donc et pas très malade 1
je sais bien qu'il ya certaines
minorités que certaines personnes à
risque sont malades mais voilà donc
globalement c'est un signe pas les gens
à se vacciner et de toute façon se
vacciner contre une maladie infectieuse
qui est en cours chez un individu et
bien je vous dis je ne sais pas ce qu'on
fait en termes infectiologie qu jeu
quand même professeur de maladies
infectieuses j'ai 40 ans d'expérience
des vanniers infectieuses non je suis
désolé et je pense avoir une culture
générale des maladies infectieuses je
n'ai jamais vu ça vacciner des gens
contre une maladie qui est en cours chez
eux
qui a dit que ça ne pouvait pas
déclencher une réponse immunitaire
inappropriée
personnes ont lancé strictement rien ça
n'a jamais été fait dans l'histoire de
la médecine donc voilà
ça c'est un principe de base après pour
répondre au député arnaud pardon aux
sénateurs excusez moi
oui je pense qu'il faut revoir il ya un
gros problème dans la formation des
médecins tout à fait conforme puis les
humanistes ce qui est une véritable
catastrophe pour ce métier on forme des
scientifiques or la médecine
contrairement à ce que beaucoup croient
n'est absolument pas une science la
médecine est un art qui se sert de la
science et de la technique je ne nie pas
dit où l'importance de la science et de
la technique dans notre art mais avant
tout c'est un art nous sommes tous
différents nous devons tous être
approchée de manière différente aux
virique demain l'évolution ça sera la
médecine personnalisée c'est à dire
qu'on aura une médecine à la carte alors
aujourd'hui on ne raconte exactement le
contraire on nous raconte qu'on est tous
pareils ou presque donc voilà il ya 10 à
toutes ces choses à revoir et
effectivement je pense que là c'est ce
que j'ai écrit dans le livre sur la
maladie de lyme j'espérais un jour être
être
disons cité pour mon livre sur la
maladie de lyme qui je pense est très
important parce que je discute du
problème de la formation des médecins
qui pour moi est une véritable enfin
très inquiétante actuellement c'est à
dire on les forme pas écouté des malades
on les forme à utiliser des algorithmes
qui est à mon avis une aberration quand
on a un malade en face de soi pour
lequel le dialogue médecin malade et
quand même la pierre angulaire de la
prise en charge voilà je veux pas
mobilisé la conversation
mais globalement
professeur lina
merci beaucoup il y avait effectivement
beaucoup de questions et des questions
intéressantes comment dire
pour les questions de monsieur karoutchi
concernant la vaccination et la
vaccination contre tous les variants en
fait c'est un objectif effectivement on
se dit on aimerait bien avoir ce qu'on
appelle une vaccination pas encore aux
navires us qui permettrait de protéger
contre tous les variances ne et quand on
parle de tout de variance et les
variants passé et variant à venir la
grosse difficulté avec les parents à
venir c'est qu'on ne les connaît pas et
qu'en revanche on sait que ces virus
sont capables d'échapper à une réponse
immunitaire des anticorps immoral par
modification dans cette fameuse protéine
qui est à la surface du virus et le
potentiel évolutif sur cette protéine
est gigantesque
donc pour l'instant ce que l'on essaie
de faire c'est de
optimiser au mieux les vaccins utilisés
pour qu'il soit capable de répondre aux
virus qui circulent et y circulent de
façon massive et notamment on prend ça
au micron mais il ya des développements
méthodologiques en cours actuellement
pour essayé d'inclure de nouveaux
épitopes en quelque sorte des composants
de vaccins complémentaire à cette
protéine qui permettrait d'agir une
limite est plus large et qui de fait
très plus protectrice mais imaginez
aujourd'hui à mon avis que l'on puisse
avoir avec 5 qui protègera contre tous
les variantes du futur est un leurre
cette salle je crois pas qu'on soit
capable de le faire la technologie
et tout simplement la capacité du virus
à évoluer ne nous permettra pas vous
avez fait une insiste sur les vaccins et
les autres vaccins
aujourd'hui les vaccins les autres
vaccins comme novavax ou comme d'autres
qui peuvent circuler ont des
performances de protection qui sont
moins bonnes que celles de la rn message
est alors ils peuvent venir en
complément temps pour élargir la la le
panorama des différents vaccins
utilisable parce que certains hrw règne
enfin on compteur d'utiliser des vaccins
arn messagers et veulent utiliser des
vaccins qui sont avec des technologies
dirai plus conventionnel mais c'est le
vaccin qui ont des performances sont
globalement moins bonne que celle de la
rn message et il reste une vraie
évolution à faire sur cette vaccination
c'est la vexation mucosal et vous avez
raison que si on veut pouvoir lutter
contre la transmission
il faut qu'on soit capable d'induire une
réponse mucosal avec ce qu'on appelle
des iga sécrétoire ou en tout cas des
réponses immunitaires locales au niveau
de la muqueuse nasale et de la muqueuse
oropharyngés en général pour
freiner encore mieux le risque de
transmission et ça c'est important
l'est vous avez posé une question aussi
concernant le problème de lisibilité
delà de la politique et vous et vous
pointez du doigt le fait qu'il ya en
fait une hétérogénéité considérables au
niveau des différents pays il ya même un
pays qui a pris une décision qui est
encore plus drastique que ce que vous
avez imaginé la surveillance a décidé
d'arrêter toute surveillance donc en
fait il considère que maintenant le
problème est résolu et donc ça ne vaut
même plus le coup de faire quoi que ce
soit pour surveiller le coronavirus
c'est terminé donc voyez entre entre la
chine qui a une stratégie zéro co vide
ou en cloisons calfeutrer on cloître des
gens dès qu'ils en a un qui est infecté
et la suède qui le dit mais je regarde
même plus quel est le niveau de
circulation de virus puisque ça ne
m'intéresse plus forcément on a tous les
on a tous les champs du possible et donc
7 7 7 7 cette analyse là et il la
réponse que l'on peut porté là dessus
elle passe effectivement par
probablement mais ça rejoint un petit
peu une question qui avait été évoqué
par monsieur arnaud c'est de dire quel
est le bon critère de jugement pour
savoir quelle est la bonne réponse en
sachant qu'on est forcément dans une
dynamique et évolutif puisque l'épidémie
évolue et que la situation vous l'avez
dit vous-même celle que l'on avait cet
été n'est pas du tout la même que celle
que l'on a aujourd'hui donc forcément la
réponse est bonne fille est évolutive et
c'est peut-être juste de prédire qui lie
à cette évolution et de l'annoncer en
disant on va aller et que cette
évolution un manque ablement elle va
aller vers plus de souplesse mais que
malgré tout on a en fonction des
indicateurs qui existe un certain nombre
de seuils qui qui ne peuvent pas
déclencher un assouplissement tant
qu'ils ne sont pas atteints et donc c
c'est toute la difficulté de deux sets
de 7 désescalade des mesures qui est
indispensable mais qui est terriblement
compliqué en sachant que en général et
c'est un petit peu et vous me
permettrait de me moquer gentiment de
vous un petit peu un problème des
politiques et des journalistes c'est que
vous voulez un calendrier mais on est
incapable de vous donner un calendrier
on est totalement et je peux pas vous
dire qui est qu'est-ce qui va vous
permettre de dire que la situation entre
le 15 février et le 18 février justifie
qu'une décision soit prise plus le 15
que le 18 moi je ne peux pas vous donner
cette information ça n'existe pas ou
alors on se lance dans des hypothèses
mais globalement un indicateur n'a de
sens je pense que victoria l'expliquera
encore mieux qu'à partir du moment où il
est robuste il est durable et qu'on sait
que la tendance qu'il montre est une
tendance qui est une tendance de fond et
ça n'est qu'après une analyse a
posteriori d'un indicateur qu'on est
capable de dire qu'effectivement il est
capable de jouer son rôle pour dire
qu'on peut enclencher la désescalade
sans qu'il y ait une prise de risque
monsieur arnaud vous avez aussi posé une
question sur les médicaments alors oui
clairement le fait qu'ils aient leur nez
des médicaments change considérablement
la donne en sachant qu' il ya une
prudence qu'il faut quoi et qu'il faut
avoir malgré tous un médicament n'est
pas un substitut d'un vaccin le vaccin
c'est empêche d'être infectés ça empêche
de faire une forme grave le médicament
il sert à traiter quelqu'un qui est déjà
malade qui donc a joué son rôle dans le
processus de transmission et de risque
de diffusion du virus par la
transmission interhumaine
malgré tout ça permet d'éviter ce que
l'on voit c'est à dire certain
engorgement de deux hôpitaux en
particulier pour les plus fragiles donc
le pacs le vide qui est donc le
médicament qui aujourd'hui commence à
pouvoir être utilisée est un médicament
qu'il semble présenter une efficacité
qui est de bonne qualité
ça reste à confirmer en vie vrai mais
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui va
normalement permettre de simplifier la
gestion de l'infection et faciliter la
sortie crise
concernant la formation des médecins où
on risque des maladies infectieuses
émergentes je vous rejoins il existe des
des sites de formation mais qui sont
très limités qui sont dédiés souvent d
un certain nombre de médecins qui ont
sont déjà sensibilisés à ça mais je
pense que là aujourd'hui on voit que
toute la communication qui a pu être
faite autour du coronavirus va inciter
beaucoup de monde à je l'espère en tout
cas à ne pas oublier sur le long terme
comment on a pu gérer cette crise bien
ou mal quelles sont nos succès que ce
sont nos échecs et de façon à ce que
aujourd'hui on est une compréhension qui
ne soit pas qu'une compréhension
technique mais qui soient effectivement
une compréhension de santé et surtout le
rôle majeur que peut jouer la santé
publique dans la gestion d'une crise
comme celle-ci et on sait à quel point
la santé publique en français et
probablement un parent pauvre
la communication entre les politiques et
les scientifiques c'est une question il
faudrait des jours et des jours donc je
vais pas trop me lancer là dessus
sachez que vous ne pouvez pas faire la
communication scientifique politique
sans inclure les médias dedans et si
vous ne faites pas un triptyque pour
essayer de comprendre en fait vous allez
vous avez vous dans des vous avez vous
embarquer dans des interprétations qui
sont pros longue pas bonne il doit y
avoir de la communication scientifique
direct vers le politique et le change
vous savez à quel point le conseil
scientifique et essaye d'avoir ce type
de communication mais il n'empêche qu'à
un moment donné les médias rentrer dans
le jeu de la communication forcément
c'est leur métier et que c'est pas
toujours ce qui est le plus simple à
gérer
mais enfin vous avez vous avez fini avec
une question sur le risque émergent de
nouveaux mâles de variants quel niveau
de risque
c'est de nouveau quelque chose où je
peux pas vous donner un pourcentage on
ne peut pas dire que ce le risque
n'existe pas mais ça n'est pas le plus
probable
voilà ce que je pouvais mais c'est une
réponse tout à fait tout et à tout à
fait utile au débat donc merci beaucoup
et vitoria colza et puis après ce sont
nos collègues qui vous interromps
parfait alors
voilà il ya il ya deux éléments jeu je
reviens sur la partie communication vous
qu'on ne s'est presque arrêtée là
et qui à l'impact inévitablement sur les
comportements alors on sait bien que si
on parle d'une épidémie de maladies
infectieuses les contacts les
interactions le comportement des
individus
correspondraient présente vraiment le
coeur de cette propagation correspondent
au tissu social sur lesquelles
l'épidémie se propage donc
inévitablement vont avoir un impact très
important est ce qu on avait déjà
découvert dans des épidémies du passé
mais que notamment sur cette vente d'emi
a été vraiment éclatante que tout la
communication elle même va impacter
aussi le comportement et puis il ya
cette circle de feedback qui continuent
à circuler
avec un impact l'un sur l'autre je
regardais hier pour me préparer pour ces
maintenant les comportements à des
enquêtes qui sont faits au cours de
temps et par exemple je regardais un
indicateur qui est donc la question
posée aux participants à cette enquête s
en cause du creux vide est-ce que vous
avez évité de lieux bondés des personnes
parce qu ayant majeur sous entendu il
est en majorité de contamination alors
qu'aujourd'hui pas aujourd'hui
effectivement c'était du buffet en fin
décembre début janvier en plein
ascension de la vague donc croissance de
la vague au micro on ne se retrouver au
même niveau de ce qu'on avait enregistré
l'été dernier
donc dans des conditions que moi gérer
dit complètement différente parce que je
connais bien évidemment la situation
épidémique donc je je je m'attendais
voilà des conditions beaucoup ont
répondu beaucoup plus faible à cette
beaucoup plus élevé des personnes qui
évite cette ces types de
des comportements par rapport c'est
qu'on avait l'été dernière qu'ils
étaient en situation assez
gérable même un présence de la vague
estivale delta
et là il ya effectivement tout
surnom notre pour mon métier en
particulier
les comportements vont être un élément
critique aussi pour notre capacité de
pouvoir anticiper ce qui va se passer
parce que si dans certains communication
à cause de certaines communications en
cause dans la racine ti et à moins des
personnes qui vont se faire vacciner
inévitablement tout ça va avoir un
impact
après sur la propagation
en termes de vaccination là aussi je
pense qu'il y a et pour pour avoir fait
un peu de communication autour des
éléments donc pour l'éclairage autour de
cette épidémie pendant ces deux années
je vois deux éléments qui sont assez
difficiles à communiquer un qui a été
déjà mentionnés par les professeurs
l'ena qui l évolution alors que
l'incertitude est très difficile à
accepter
les gens inévitablement en s'être ainsi
tissé besoin d'avoir un certain nombre
de certitudes surtout qu'ils n'évoluent
pas avec les temps et c'est complètement
en contraste avec le projet su qu'on a
en face le deuxième élément est la
simplification alors bien évidemment
qu'il ya un processus assez complexe
qu'on doit simplifier quand on fait de
la communication
mais l'hiver simplification n'aide pas
de tout eva exactions de l'autre côté là
la protection du vaccin contre
l'infection et ans
exemple clé c'est vrai que le vaccin
n'empêche pas l'infection mais la réduit
et là c'est toute la différence dans les
cadres on essaie de simplifier ses
messages entre 0 1 donc on ne pêche pas
donc c'est sa protection contre
l'infection à zéro et c'est pas vrai au
moment d'en mourir contre au micro-ondes
vaccination qui vient d'être fait réduit
la cote la l'infection la probabilité
d'infection de 70 % après 3 mois elle a
réduit à moitié mais dans le cadre d'une
lutte à cette pandémie on a besoin on a
toujours besoin de plusieurs couches de
plusieurs niveaux de réponse on porte
toujours les masques on continue à 20000
et les locaux on l'a mise à disposition
un certain nombre des mesures de
préventive des protections chacune va
apporter un certain pourcentage de
réponses donc voilà tiens le vaccin est
même 50% efficace contre l'infection
effectivement c'est en fait une
protection énorme les révisions ça
n'empêche d'avoir une probation si large
que micron et alors là c'est la
difficulté vraiment de de pouvoir
élaborer économique et ses messages avec
le deux éléments
l'autre et je pense l'autre
en termes de voix la un terme des
politiques je veux pas
mettre des commentaires jeu sur sur les
choix politiques mais bien évidemment je
pense que d'un point de vue pourvoir
répondre à ces questions pour nos
scientifiques et dans l'incertitude
totale on fait bien évidemment des
scénarios auxquels on ne peut pas
associer des probabilités des
réalisations donc on fait des hypothèses
de sueur qui est plausible qui qui
pourrait se passer dans certaines
conditions mais l'élément qui qui nous
aiderait serré vraiment de pouvoir
établir des objectifs etc qui nous
manquera donc la réponse en terme de
cette politique est-ce que l est
approprié ou pas pour cette situation
épidémique doit être associé à un
objectif
et si la première phase de la pandémie
et des est un point de vue un peu
paradoxal plus simple en terme de
d'établir à ses objectifs on avait bien
évidemment des des vagues
catastrophique et donc la décision les
occulte il était assez clair réduire la
spéculation et réduire le nombre des
personnes qui arrivaient à l'hôpital
dans cette phase qui nous qui nous
attend ça ça va devenir de plus en plus
difficile d'établir ce type d'objectif
et je pense que c'est en discussion
qu'on avait soulevé déjà la semaine
dernière au cours de la commission de la
quête qui est bien évidemment c'est pas
aux scientifiques de les faire mais je
pense qu'il faudrait avoir une
discussion autour de ces qui est
ce tenable c'était acceptable en termes
d'impact épidémique sur la société et
sur la base des six critères après
pouvoir donc établir quelles sont les
mesures pour nous permettre de corée de
2,2 de répondre à ces objectifs là
merci ça on ne peut que souscrire en
tout cas à ses propos et regretté le
manque de délibération collective autour
des objectifs mais ça en aidant on est
dans une ville qu'on fasse de la
politique professeur comme dans la mode
de gestion de cette pandémie nous avons
dénoncé en permanence le culte du secret
la permanence du conseil de défense
sanitaire et l'absence de débat avec le
parlement autour de ces deux objectifs
on convoque le parlement pour voter sur
le pass vaccinale au forceps pour lui
intimer l'ordre de délibérer en 48
heures et pour hurler parce que l raison
les députés refusant débute dans
débattent à 4 heures du matin parce
qu'il a aucune urgence
là il ya une pression politique est
forte mais quand il s'agit effectivement
c'est fondamental de savoir c'est notre
interrogation quelles sont nos objectifs
pour les six mois l'année les années à
venir et on veut fonder notre
délibération sur la connaissance
scientifique parce qu'elle est à la base
elle reste à la base de notre
délibération et avec les incertitudes et
avec après nous dans la décision
politique les facteurs humains sociétaux
économiques le ce qu'est une vie en
commun et donc comment est-ce qu'on doit
vie maintenant avec ce virus avec le
schéma que vous nous avez décrit d'une
d'un virus qui s'installe
progressivement perdre sa dangerosité
fini peut-être comme la grippe avec des
résurgences ma foi qui pose pas de gros
problèmes à notre système de soins à
notre société voilà où est ce qu'on doit
s'attendre à un scénario moins
moins plaisant on va dire qui entend
genre a à nouveau des dégâts nenê c'est
des mesures nécessaires de protection et
de restrictions liberté c'est exactement
ça mais on ne peut que encore une fois
souligner le défaut dans notre pays deux
débats collectifs
je pense que je vous espérez que les
membres du conseil scientifique ont ces
débats entre eux mais le conseil
scientifique n'est pas une instance
politique bien que les politiques
parfois se mêle de vouloir trancher les
débats scientifiques mais les
responsables d'un centre scientifique se
mêle parfois aussi de vouloir trancher
des débats politiques on peut aussi
noter ce mode de descendre la crise sans
volonté polémique aucune et dans le
grand respect que nous avons pour les
institutions de notre pays y compris
scientifiques bien sûr esther benbassa
notre collègue veut vous interrogez
merci d'être là vous avait éclairé un
petit peu l'horizon sans nous donner des
réponses précises c'est normal
puisque je ne crois pas qu'il y ait pour
le moment de réponse précise à donner
d'abord je viendrai un professeur comme
sur votre modèle historique
écoutez vous voulez pas seulement vous
baser sur ce modèle du 19e siècle depuis
il ya eu la pénicilline depuis il ya eu
il y a eu des découvertes et puis il ya
eu la grippe espagnole qui est passée
par là et c'est donc est-ce que ce
modèle et est valable aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas peut-être ça peut servir d'un
10 mai pas plus si je puis me permettre
de faire cette remarque
sur
sur l'histoire de du virus
je viens je voudrais poser aux
professeurs l'humain en tant
qu'écologiste une question sur les
animaux vous parlez de ces animaux qui
consorte de leur
disons de leur milieu pour les
par exemple les visons et cetera les
animaux même domestique est ce que il y
a aussi un effet de la déforestation qui
serait disons à la base de cette
transmissibilité des animaux vers les
hommes d'ailleurs des hommes et des
femmes vers les animaux aussi
probablement pour les animaux
domestiques et autres
je voudrais bien savoir s'il s'agit d'un
milk ou d'une réalité
et troisièmement une question innocente
d'un culte en sciences
écoutez que vous parlez et
on a en parlé très brièvement de la
grippe et il ya eu
d'autres maladies qu'on a qu'on a pu
disons stoppé par le vaccin par exemple
la tuberculose
il y a toujours la tuberculose
voilà la grippe il ya toujours la grippe
mais est-ce que et il faut peut-être
éclairer nos citoyens mais citoyen sur
le fait que dans l'avenir une fois la
période d'épidémie traversée il y aura
une adaptation
des vaccins même il faudra les adapter
quoi qu'il arrive
puisque
la grippe le virus il évolue et l'évolué
on adapte les ans ou tous les deux ans
je ne connais pas la fréquence et
au virus lui même pourquoi la chose ne
serait pas pareil pour
pour le colonat virus
voilà je voudrais une réponse parce que
c'est panique de la population voit sur
le terrain c'est panique d'abord je ne
veux pas critiquer la communication
puisque je connais aussi les bienfaits
de la communication pour l'information
tout en moi mais ce qui inquiète les
françaises et les français qu'on voit
sur le terrain c est la diversité des
réponses qui sont donnés
parler dans les médias par des savants
je sais pas si c'est vous mais par
diverses avant qu'ils ont des discours
très différents et cela vraiment des
boussoles les gens il faut le dire aussi
ils savent pas à quel saint se vouer
chacun a une explication
il ya les stars qui dit ça l'est moins
ce talent qui disent ça et c'est bon là
il y a un vrai problème et de
compréhension parce que nous sommes
perdus c'est la vérité on parle pas
assez non plus du médicament là vous
avez parlé je suppose du pacs le vide
qui est quand même probablement si les
essais on va l'utilisation et efficace
ça sera quand même une voie de sortie
si si c'est pas je ne sais pas vous
n'êtes pas convaincu bombe le mans de
mou moi je ne m'y connais pas mais il y
a des vaccins il y à des médicaments et
il ya la panique alors il ya quelque
chose qui va pas la panique chez la
population où
j'étais 45 ans prof et où
la pédagogie n'est pas bonne parce qu'il
ya n'a pas dit où c'est les les
les médias qui clôt la famille parce que
c'est quand même ça marche bien tous les
soirs on a dû qu'aux vide ça remplit les
programmes et en période de
l'électoral comme on n'a pas un grand un
programme très important que nos
candidats n'ont pas de programme très
intéressant
et alors le coc vide rempli
ce ce vide alors voilà brièvement mais
question avec mon inquiétude à moi aussi
moi j'ai eu le col idée j'ai été vacciné
trois fois bon je m'attends prochain
mais alors ce sera une explosion au
micro bien voilà et d'ailleurs nous
avons des prêts qui sont vision parce qu
il faut vider vacciner trois fois je
vais vous repassez à tous les trois la
parole pour si vous avez des éléments de
réponse à apporter à notre collègue et
servane bataille puis pour un mot de
conclusion si vous le souhaitez
professeur tonn
écoutez je peins ou répondre à la
question concernant les vaccins la
grille parce que vous avez quand même le
spécialiste français la question qui est
juste sur l'écran donc je pense qu'ils
connaissent à beaucoup mieux - pour le
médicament passe le vide attention
il n'a pas été évalué correctement sur
les variants qui vont émerger
est il d'ailleurs
je fais cette remarque il n'y a toujours
pas de publications scientifiques ce qui
est absolument invraisemblable
c'est la première fois que je vois ça
una est même autorisé sans publication
scientifique
ça m'a beaucoup étonné voilà est par
ailleurs il y aura un problème de
disponibilité
qui n'a apparemment est soulevée par pas
beaucoup de monde mais mes collègues
américains me disent qu'il ya un
problème de disponibilité comme les
médicaments est déjà commercialisé aux
états unis je pense qu'ils ont raison
et par ailleurs en matière de virus si
vous ne démarrez pas le traitement dans
les 24 à les 48 premières heures au
maximum vous ne pouvez pas être efficace
donc et ça c'est valable pour les
repaissent est valable pour le zona
c'est parfait c'est valable pour la
plupart des maladies virales c'est
valable pour la grippe dont on a tant
parlé la grippe vous démarrez pas le
traitement dans les 48 premières heures
de desing vous n'êtes pas efficace quoi
donc ça c'est une notion vraiment à
prendre en compte ça n'empêchera pas la
circulation du virus voilà mes mais ça
empêchera ou aux personnes à risque
d'être malade et de rentrer à l'hôpital
ou en réanimation quant à la remarque
que vous avez fait sur l'histoire bon je
vous avoue je suis un peu triste
d'entendre dans cet ensemble que
l'histoire
on peut pas compter dessus je pense pas
comme vous je vous le dis franchement
d'ailleurs je vous invite à regarder
l'historique de l'épidémie de grippe
russe et vous allez voir que c'était
presque écrit voilà merci professeur
lina
oui merci beaucoup merci à l'impôt c'est
pour ces questions je vais commencer par
votre dernière remarque
ce coronavirus mais c'est incroyablement
compliqué fuck boîtier les pleins de
choses que je comprends pas je romps
qu'on peut faire on peut faire les
fanfarons essayé de raconter et
expliquer mais c'est très très très
compliqué c'est impossible de faire de
cette histoire une histoire simple et ça
a déjà été évoqué par vitoria lippert
simplification est une très mauvaise
stratégie parce qu'elle est prise en
défaut très régulièrement donc on a
besoin de communiquer sur le fait que
c'est très compliqué et quand on dit que
c'est très compliqué ça suppose qu'il y
à des réflexions scientifiques et je
remonte un petit peu les questions que
vous allez poser que vous avez posé et
que ces questions scientifiques
habituellement c'est des débats qu'on a
entre nous et là c'est des débats qui
maintenant ont lieu sur des plateaux
télévisés et c'est là où vous avez le
sentiment que il ya une incohérence par
rapport à la position d'un certain
nombre de personnes qui ne pensent pas
la même chose mais qui s'y sont des bons
scientifiques et en l'occurrence je
pense que dans un certain nombre de
casses et c'est la réalité les travaux
les études vont permettre de répondre à
la question et
d'éclairer le sujet sur lequel ils
débattent pour qu'au bout du compte tout
le monde consensuellement est d'accord
pour dire que et bien parmi les
hypothèses qu'il y avait au départ qui
étaient toutes légitimes qui ont été
testées et bien il y en a une qui est de
la vérité les choses ne sont que deux
hypothèses qui ont été invalidés donc
c'est le sens que c'est le fait d'avoir
médiatisé ce débat scientifique avec
parfois des comportements d'un certain
nombre de scientifiques qui étaient
treize outrancier qui qui qui a
probablement terni un petit peu à
l'image de ce que peut être la réflexion
scientifique mais vous trompez pas c'est
pas quelque chose qui à six est apparu
avec avec l'actrice de micron c'est
juste que c'est devenu un peu plus
visible on est parfois en désaccord mais
on s'invective pas forcément on dit
simplement qu'on n'est pas d'accord les
uns avec les autres
concernant la la vaccination et après je
terminerai sur la question de
l'environnement
la vaccination un objectif qui est de
réduire le risque c'est la vaccination
ne permet jamais d'avoir un risque zéro
jamais tous les vaccins peuvent être
pris en défaut à un moment donné quel
qu'il soit et donc on ne peut ce n'est
pas une armure impénétrable qui vous
permet d'avoir un statut permettant
d'éviter toute autre mesure qui
permettent de qui qui pourraient
éventuellement conduire est une
affection
donc c'est à partir du moment où on
comprend que on est dans une réduction
du risque et non pas une mais vous voir
une atténuation très significatif mais
pas une disparition du risque que on
voit que la vaccination fait partie
d'outils qui permettent de maîtriser un
risque infectieux individuelle et
populationnelle
[Musique]